[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome Channel Awesome's
orbit report you're a source for
everything happening around the world
and pop culture and entertainment news
I'm Heather Ruth and I'm Anna wave and
this is your news for Monday February
12th Disney has begun casting for a
live-action
Kim Possible movie only beat me if you
want to reach me yes that is right
children of the early 2000s
Kim Possible is getting a live action
movie it's going to be a Disney Channel
Original Movie and they have their just
started casting it so they have no
release date or anything
any news about when it's going to be
coming out but who would you guys like
to see play Kim Possible um personally I
would like to see Madeline patch who
plays of Cheryl in a Riverdale I think
she's got the right look for that but
let us know in the comments who you guys
would like to see play Kim Possible in a
live-action remake remember she's in
high school as well as our favorite
redheaded actresses and aged out of that
and that's okay we've accepted it Thank
You Disney also this week announced that
they have some other things coming to
their streaming service first the big
one is that they're doing the
live-action sword in the stone remake
exclusively for the streaming service
and I think this is a pretty bold move
considering that the rest of their
remakes have been theatrical releases so
they're definitely trying to entice
other people to buy the service who
maybe wouldn't be so keen on buying
service so it's going to be exclusively
now on the streaming service they're
also trying to entice some people with
not just one but multiple Star Wars
shows including a live-action one and
I'm assuming the other ones or one might
be animated but it's definitely going to
be a live-action one and they're keeping
a pretty tight lid on what's going on
with some of those projects just saying
that there's gonna be multiple Star Wars
shows and the live-action sword ins
zone so be ready for that with the
Disney streaming service I've got a
suggestion Disney streaming service pick
up galavant Disney owns ABC galavant is
on ABC was on ABC dance trade show
you've already got Alan Menken doing the
music we know he works well with Disney
in the past just saying
bring it back we miss it you do just
saying
and also it's more of a mature audience
and so for the Disney streaming service
already just having the library of
Disney movies is gonna be incredible on
a streaming service let's be real yeah
but also having some more stuff for
adults to be watching on there is pretty
smart so just put it out there yeah yeah
also also Disney Kingdom Hearts 3
released a trailer at the Japanese d23
this weekend it looks amazing and I'm
excited and it's still coming out in
2018 at some point
supposedly well I'm hoping we'll have
more news on that soon but other than
that we did get a sneak peek at the
monsters ink world which looked really
cool Sora and Donald and Goofy were all
monsters in the world and there was what
was that Keyblade I don't know it looks
insane yeah that's like it can transform
to quite it quite a few different things
it was a wrench and then for a second
it's a door and then it's dueling yo-yos
it's all of the above I don't know maybe
it's got that little like construction
helmet oh yeah I'm man that looks like a
really fun world you can skate around on
the doors and everything too and the
design looks amazing we also got a
little bit of each tangled world yeah
which looks like it still needs a little
work but still really really really cool
and I'm very excited and the keyblade's
I'm just excited for all the things we
previously got a trailer that had that
Japanese James Wood how they pulled that
off voice actors are that was amazing
and this actually topped that for me
with just that sneak peek of the
monsters eat world in that keyblade oh
my god oh my god looks great
again hopefully we'll keep our fingers
crossed for a true 2018 release date
because it's been a while since we've
had a new king of our
game is busy right let's get more Disney
things that happen this week we finally
finally have a trailer for solo was it
worth it yeah Donna Glover what one gets
1,000% I am gonna see that movie just
for Donald Robert Glover I'm sorry
Lando 100% yeah very excited about that
although it didn't seem like it has a
lot of action I was really interested in
seeing a brand new looking Millennium
Falcon
wait whoa oh my gosh whatever white one
do done the milk it and then it has the
closed nose as well so I don't I'm
curious to see how it's gonna the nose
is gonna change and morph if it's I'm
calling it's gonna be the open-ended one
that we're used to by the end of the
movie I'm calling that we'll see we'll
see but one of the things that intrigued
me the most is it seems like they may be
bringing some extended universe lore
into this because Han Solo does mention
in the trailer briefly that he applied
for the flight Academy but was kicked
out which does also happen in the
extended universe which is not canon
anymore before it does happen in the
extended universe that way as well
except the reason that Han gets kicked
out of flight academy in the extended
universe is because he frees an imperial
slave who is young so I really hope they
do keep that because I think that it
worked really well in the extended
universe and it should be a cinematic
thing as well also this week we've got a
trailer for season two of Jessica Jones
which I am very excited about Jessica
Jones is one of my favorite Marvel
Netflix shows and so it seems like it
has a lot of the same action and quips
and dialogue that we have come to know
and love with Jessica Jones and Krysten
Ritter doing such a wonderful job with
that lots of drinking lots of action it
seems like alias investigations might be
absorbed into another company so there's
that conflict going on but then the main
thing that we need to speculate about is
is killgrave back there was a fight
there's a purple light a purple clapping
hands
I think with the light maybe that means
that he'll come back as some kind of
figment of her imagination or ghosts I
mean his powers did reside in the mind
so it could very well be that there's
some residual powers working around in
there oh yeah we don't have to wait long
that's out George yep Marv Jason also
this week we had a Deadpool 2 trailer
that introduced us to cable whoo Josh
Brolin looks amazing right he looks
absolutely just screen perfect he really
does and the trailer is hilarious and
action-packed as you would expect from
Deadpool at this point I honestly won't
even be able to do it with justice go
watch the trailer it's so funny and just
the little action figures of Deadpool as
Sheriff Woody
a little Justice League jab in there too
about the mustache Oh shade so it just
looks packed with just hilarious
dialogue and action don't go check that
trailer out we can see that movie on the
18 yay also this week we got the
much-anticipated
venom trailer with Tom Hardy a lot of us
have the question though where's then
why why did you release the trailer
interested you don't have yeah I'm ready
I don't know what is venom gonna look
like I have some thoughts as to what it
should look like they've got until
October yeah when it is going to release
but I'm not sure why we didn't see venom
in this yeah I mean yeah it's possible
that they're saving anticipation but it
makes me less excited for it interesting
in spider-man 3 the way they handle
venom was with the honeycomb webbing on
the suits which made sense because the
symbiote took over spider-man suit
however this is a standalone film so I'm
not sure what the suits going to look
like I know they had some design issues
in spider-man 3 not wanting it to be
latex because it looked a little bit
like a gimp suit don't Google that or
keep your SafeSearch huh and so I'm
interested to see what the suits gonna
look like what size he's going to be we
know Tom Hardy can look massive yes as
Bane he looks like a big
dude so I would like a large venom I
think that makes more sense I'm
interested to see what the mouth is
gonna look like I don't use those teeth
things cuz actors have problems talking
around them yeah but are they going to
do an animatronic mouth to have more of
a just humanoid but not quite human
mouth how are the eyes gonna be giant
there's so many ways this could look I'm
really interested I'm hoping they do
some practical effects oh they've done
practical effects and they're really
into CGI nowadays but it could go the
green lantern route so nope who have
very many worries about what that was
gonna look like but I hope it's I hope
it's treated with the care and interest
imagination of design that I know it can
be it can be but we'll see so you gotta
wait and see otherwise that's gonna be
it from us this week I know this was a
jam-packed episode but if there's
something we missed that you would like
us to talk about let us know in the
comments down below we're also going to
be on top 5 tomorrow because Walter is
not back so use hashtag where's Walter
and let us know in the comments or other
social media where you think Walter has
gone Heather if people want to tell you
that on social media where can they find
you you can find me on Twitter at
Heather Ruth's Instagram at a truce or
twitch twitch TV slash Heather ruse and
I'm on Facebook as I an away tour
everywhere else as awesome Ayanna and
that's gonna be it from us we'll see you
in the comments down below or tomorrow
on top 5 in the meantime can you beam us
up
[Applause]
you